our next speaker is becoming a regular
at Hillsdale College events kimberly's
Drossel is a member of the editorial
board of the Wall Street Journal where
she writes editorials as well as the
weekly Potomac watch column she began
her career in the news department at the
Wall Street Journal Wall Street Journal
Europe first in Brussels and then in
London later in New York she joined the
journals editorial page assuming her
current position in 2005 a recipient of
the 2014 Bradley prize she is I think
it's safe to say often a lone voice of
reason on the Sunday morning news shows
as president Arne mentioned she spent
two weeks in residence on the Hillsdale
campus in the fall of 2013 as a Pulliam
journalism fellow in addition to her
top-notch journalism she is the author
of the national bestseller the
intimidation game how the left is
silencing free speech she gave a talk on
that subject last year at the college's
Kirby Center which we were pleased to
publishing and Primus she's been writing
a lot lately about the subject of her
talk tonight the need to drain the swamp
at the swamp in Washington DC that is
not here in Florida all I can say is all
I can say to that is keep it up we're
delighted she is able to be with us once
again
please welcome Kimberly's Drossel
[Applause]
good evening Hillsdale we already well
first of all I want to thank Tim and dr.
Arnn for such a nice introduction I
particularly like Larry's Felicity with
words when Larry says great with child
what he means is that I looked like the
USS Enterprise giving a speech in front
of Hillsdale that time and it was funny
when he mentioned that I remembered he
just brought to mind another funny
moment because I've actually had a
number of children and have been great
with child in a number of other
situations and one time when my second
was due I got invited in to george w
bush's White House for an off-the-record
press briefing that he was doing with
some conservative journalists and I was
still 10 days out from delivery but
looking pretty large with child and I
got sat right next to the president and
you could tell he was nervous and he
looked at me and he said stressful when
you do and I looked at him you know he's
a jokester and he deserves to get a
little bit of it back sometimes and I
just looked at him straight in the eye
and I said oh it was a week ago
and he asked if the White House doctor
was in residence but even better was
that Charles Krauthammer was there and
he looked across the table and said
don't worry I'm a doctor so I always
feel so honored when Hillsdale does ask
me to speak and it's because while I
have not spent an enormous amount of
time on campus it is a place that has
become very dear to my heart I was asked
a few years back to come and be a
Pulliam fellow and by John Miller who is
the amazing guy who runs the journalism
Center there at school and it was two
weeks
that was absolutely transformative to me
because prior to that moment I could
never understand why anyone on God's
earth would ever choose to educate
children I have three of my own I spend
most of my time trying to hide from them
I don't know why you would do it but
being there seeing the institution
seeing the quality of the staff seeing
the extraordinary level of the
curriculum and most of all seeing the
students it was awe-inspiring to me and
within a week I had totally thrown John
Miller under the bus I was sideling up
to Larry telling him why he needed to
fire his current journalism director and
keep me there
luckily Larry with all of his writing
about Churchill and World War 2 he's
very wise to the dark arts of saboteurs
so Hillsdale was saved from that but
this is a way of saying that all of you
who either work for the school or
support the school you are doing God's
work training the next generation and I
applaud all of you
[Applause]
when I saw what Hillsdale actually
wanted me to speak about tonight that
one sentence political corruption this
won't be drained I did have a brief
internal giggle and thought that I could
make this a very short evening come up
here with the one-word answer that
everyone is expecting and then head
straight to cocktails but one of the
problems of course with being a
conservative is that you are a born
optimist and that it is our job to solve
problems and so the answer is yes the
swamp can be drained but I think what
everyone needs to understand is that
this is not something that's going to be
a small or inconsequential endeavor it's
going to take a long time and to do it
we first have to define what we mean by
the swamp and what we mean by corruption
because I think one of the problems that
we have these days is that the
definition of that has been defined by
two extremes on one side we have a group
of people that still have a dictionary
definition of public corruption and when
we think of it in that terms we tend to
think of fraud usually perpetrated for
some sort of self benefit either for
power or for money and well I wouldn't
say that that things those things don't
happen anymore these days they're pretty
rare only in that we've actually come up
with a lot of laws anti-bribery laws and
campaign finance laws transparency laws
that are designed to guard against such
obvious things like the teapot dome
stamp scandal or Tammany Hall or even
some of the excesses of the Nixon
administration that is unless your name
is Hillary Clinton but that's an
entirely different speech
and then on the other end we tend to
have people mostly commentators whose
definition of corruption is anything
that they don't like in politics
whatsoever which of course isn't really
the way the world really works they're
going to be things in politics that none
of us like and so that's not really a
fair definition of corruption either but
I think we do need to talk about it
because what we're seeing in DC is a new
type of everyday and pernicious
corruption and it comes in my mind from
as many things do the new partisan
environment that we live in and DC in
which all that matters to people is that
they win and so all of the norms all of
the rules all the regulations all of the
things that you think ought to have
applied to you they don't think apply to
them anymore
all that matters is coming out on top
and that's the kind of corruption that
now pervades Washington on a regular
basis it's what I call regular
corruption and nowhere did this
corruption flourish more than in the
past administration which infused the
federal government with a whole new
level of partisanship and moreover
managed to make a whole tens of
thousands of career bureaucrats who we
know from polls that we've done in
surveys we've done tend to share the
ideological inclinations of the past
administration brought them along with
it and we did have a new level of
everyday corruption so let's go through
what actually counts is that in my mind
one of the most common forms of
corruption we have seen especially over
the past eight years as blatant
regulatory excess and I'm not talking
here about rules with which we disagree
the executive branch is charged with
significant powers of interpreting laws
coming up with regulations many of which
people on the conservative side or the
liberal side might not always support
but if they're done within the general
outlines of the law it's something you
live with it's a consequence of an
election what I'm talking about here are
rule
that the people who put out outright new
contravened federal law outright had
admitted that they did not have the
power to put together and nonetheless
went ahead forward with it to me in my
mind knowingly breaking the law is a
form of corruption when Barack Obama ran
for the presidency in 2008 he put out a
list of the top things he wanted to
accomplish legislatively and on those
lists was a carbon cap and trade program
and he acknowledged that to do this he
would need to put it through Congress
and they tried in 2009 Democrats Henry
Waxman and Ed Markey actually passed a
bill through the house that would have
done that it never made it through the
Senate and it never had a chance of
making it through the Senate I wrote
about carbon policy for a long time
there were never more than maybe 40 or
42 votes to ever get something like this
through the Senate and yet rather than
admit defeat the president turned to his
EPA and instructed them to create the
exact same program that he was trying to
put through legislatively they knew that
they didn't have the authority to do so
and by the way to show how little
authority they did do to have that it
wasn't within a few months of it being
passed that the courts had already
halted it and ultimately the Supreme
Court put a stop on it Supreme Court was
actually pretty busy during the Obama
administration it overruled him on major
portions of Obamacare it overruled among
key portions of his immigration policy
it overruled him on search and seizure
rules on the first amendment on public
corruption cases some of you may know
the Cato Institute's Ilya Shapiro he's a
scholar there in an article in 2016 he
noted that the Obama administration had
lost more times in front of the Supreme
Court than any other modern president by
2016 he had a collective win rate in
from the Supreme Court of 45% now some
of you might think well you know you win
one you lose one but that's the standard
we hold for personal injury lawyers
okay the President of the United States
we hold them to a higher level it is
after all their duty they put their hand
up and promise to faithfully execute the
office of the presidency which includes
faithfully executing our laws Ronald
Reagan Reagan's win rate was 75 percent
George HW Bush's was 70 george w bush's
was 60 percent and by the way that was
only because he was stuck by tradition
having to defend some of the things that
the Clinton administration had stuck him
with at the end of their term which by
the way their final term was a win rate
of 35 percent in front of the Supreme
Court now at least some of the things
that the Supreme Court were overruling
were just regulatory actions there the
other form of corruption another form of
corruption in Washington that we all
have to be on guard against which is of
course executive orders and again the
White House has vast discretion to put
these out and as long as they are within
the general contours of the law they
should stand but what I'm talking about
here again are executive orders that
obviously blatantly cut across
established law right now this country
is having a debate Washington did over
the last few weeks over the status of
dreamers this came about because the
President Obama decided to put forward
his daca program which suspended the law
for this entire category of people 1.8
million people at least he had already
come out at least two occasions and said
that he didn't have the authority to do
this that he needed Congress to move in
order to make it happen and yet
nonetheless when Congress didn't move he
issued an executive order and that's
just the beginning of some of the
executive orders here's one of my
favorite ones and again it gives you a
sense of what we're talking about in
terms of corruption at the highest
levels in January 2012 the Senate was
taking a three-day break between
sessions they were not
recess President Obama nonetheless
unilaterally declared that a separate
branch of government was in recess and
used that period to appoint three
individuals to the National Labor
relation board these were people that
the unions had wanted him to appoint
they had been as biggest supporters
during the campaign and in keeping as I
said with the win at any cost mentality
he decided that he would intervene on a
separate branch of government and
declare when they were in and out of
recess he was sued ultimately and in
2014 the Supreme Court on a nine zero
decision called null canning unanimously
by the way he lost even his own Supreme
Court appointees overruled him in a
scathing decision the essence of which
was essentially you knew better than to
do this what are you thinking and I
think that's the point it's one thing
for scholars for academics to have a
debate about fuzzy points of the law
it's an entirely different thing for an
administration to abduct the mindset
that you're gonna put forward executive
orders that you know are illegal and
then wait for the Supreme Court to
police you because that was one of the
great innovations of the Obama
administration is that they understood
that you could go ahead and do these
things and it would take a long time for
anyone to catch up with you there's no
immediate remedy when a president issues
an executive order that's patently
illegal when his administration issues
regulations that are patently illegal
you have to wait for the courts to catch
up and by the way even when they do
catch up you've already accomplished
your goal and I think that's a really
good example the one I just told you
about the National Labor Relations Board
it was three years later when the
Supreme Court finally ruled again
unanimously that the President had
incontrovertibly and unconstitutionally
appointed people to an agency and even
though the court was willing at that
time to come out and stop and say that
had to be removed
it did not prove willing to reverse any
of the thousands of decisions that that
unconstitutional board had issued in the
three years before it took for the
Supreme Court to catch up with it and
again I call that a form of corruption
here's another common form of corruption
you see in Washington these days
regulators who abuse their authority and
who abuse the law to inflict punitive
measures on political rivals that same
NLRB that I was talking about for a
while had an acting general counsel
named lief Solomon again never confirmed
by the Senate he couldn't get enough
votes but he managed to run the joint
for an entire year and at one point
Boeing some of you may remember this
intended to move in a major part of its
manufacturing facilities from it's very
unionized regulated state down to South
Carolina which was a right-to-work state
leave Salomon penned an opinion all on
his own that it invented out of whole
cloth a theory saying that somehow it
was illegal for Boeing to start a
factory in a different state think about
how you come up with that but he managed
to do it
I remembered on McGann some of you may
recognize the name he's currently the
general counsel to the Trump
administration telling me about his own
time as a federal election commissioner
and he said he watched this year after
year
he watched the career staff there whose
job it is to make the first evaluation
on any complaints that came in about
political campaigning and then decide
whether or not to move those complaints
on to the commissioner sit for months
and develop novel legal theories about
how they could bring down Republican
groups even though Democratic groups
who've been accused of the same thing
we're led off these are the kind of
disparity in the way law is applied in
Washington that happened routinely we
have a Justice Department speaking of
corruption that became ace at actually
going after other politicians on public
corruption charges the prosecutors who
brought suit against former Alaska
senator
had Stevens and by the way a suit that
cost him his 2008 election and handed
Democrats a filibuster-proof majority
that they then used to pass Obamacare
and other things like the stimulus they
were abound later to have engaged in
quote reckless professional misconduct
for actions that included withholding
exculpatory evidence from the defense
the Supreme Court recently overturned
the Justice Department's conviction
against former Virginia Governor Bob
McDonnell noting it that if the Justice
Department have been allowed to get away
with a standard that it used to convict
him of corruption that pretty much every
politician in the United States would be
subject to such charges a US District
Court Judge and this is one of my
favorite I've gotta love this two years
ago ordered more than 1,000 attorneys
and I'm not making that up 1,000 in the
Justice Department's Civil Division to
undergo remedial ethics training and it
came after members of that division were
found to have deliberately misled the
judge about the president's policies
deliberately that isn't a mistake its
corruption and of course we have the IRS
targeting scandal in which career
officials at the prodding of Democrats
and the President of the United States
targeted and attacked hundreds of
conservative nonprofit groups
representing tens of thousands of
Americans they sent them harassing
letters they frightened them into
thinking that they could be sent to jail
they refused to grant them their
constitutional right to operate and
speak not just in the 2010 midterm
elections but in the 2012 presidential
elections we know from emails and
congressional investigations that Lois
Lerner who headed up this effort knew
exactly what she was doing knew it
likely violated the law knew we know
from those emails too that she was a
virulent partisan in line with many of
the policies that were being presented
by the administration who hated
conservatives and their growing
influence intellect
and she knew too that she had to hide
all of this from the public and despite
knowing all of this by the way not one
single person has yet to be held account
in that targeting scandal Lois Lerner
retired with full retirement benefits
from the federal government and that
brings me to talk what I think now is
the most nefarious form of everyday
corruption that we see and we're seeing
it happen right now even with a change
of administration and that is the
nonstop effort to shield government
officials from any accountability and to
enable and continue to enable all the
behavior that I just described you go
back and look through the past year
eight years we had a fast and furious
gun walking scandal that by most
estimates has cost hundreds of Mexicans
their lives potentially at least one
American border agent it took years to
get the bottom of it because the
Department of Justice refused to hand
over its documents and to be clear there
was no question that this was a case of
government dereliction a finer Inspector
General report ultimately were Mehcad
recommended that no less than 14
individuals be subject to discipline and
yet Attorney General Eric Holder was so
determined to make sure that nobody
found out about this that he ended up
becoming the first cabinet official in
the history of the United States to be
held in contempt of Congress we had a
veteran's of fair administration that
sat for years on the news of waiting
lists and of people dying only after the
news broke did we find out how long this
had been going on and to what links the
department had gone hide it from
congressional overseers if you want to
know why miss Lerner has never been held
to account I'll give you one reason in
2014 the Congress the House passed a
resolution of contempt against her for
lying to them
and they sent it over the Justice
Department which under the statute and
it is very clearly written shall refer
it to a US Attorney who then shall bring
it in front of a grand jury
it was duly sent to a US attorney for
the District of Columbia a man named
Machin who was an Obama appointment
point II he sat on it for 11 months and
on the day he resigned he sent a letter
to Speaker John Boehner saying that he
was refusing to take any action the
exact same thing happened when the house
sent their contempt resolution to the
Justice Department against Eric Holder
no action was ever taken we have a
former Secretary of State who set up a
private server and she knew it was
against the rules in order to shield any
of her communications while she was in
office from the public and she then
deleted all of those communications and
told us to just trust her that she would
retained all it mattered we know the
inner drive to keep secret the way she
had intersected her foundation work
whether government works she allowed
classified information to flow over
those unsecured lines and yet we also
know from recent text messages have come
out that the investigation in her was
absolutely politically tainted we have
FBI agents pointing out to each other
that the FBI ought to be careful not to
put too many people on her case because
they wouldn't want to offend the future
President of the United States of
America and of course we have the most
worrying situation of all which is an
FBI department that looks to have been
used as a pawn for a political campaign
this is an FBI that for months defied
congressional subpoenas in order to keep
quiet any of the information into its
probe the House Intelligence Committee
sent it a subpoena a duly sworn subpoena
all the way back in August it was
January before it responded to it and
only then because both House
Intelligence Committee devan newness and
speaker Paul Ryan had said that FBI
director Christopher Rea and Deputy
Attorney General rod Rosenstein would be
held in personal contempt if they didn't
finally hand over the goods everyone
should understand what's happened here
the media Democrats have done a very
good job of muddying the waters on this
issue but what we have here is very very
clear
we had one presidential campaign gin up
opposition research which was funneled
to the FBI
and then used as an excuse and a
justification to spy on a rival
presidential campaign and if you don't
think that is as scary as it gets in
terms of law enforcement and misuse of
power it is and there is no wonder that
they didn't want all this to come out
what we have learned since it did come
out is that not only that we had a
campaigns opposition research as the
basis for a FISA warrant
there was a Justice Department employee
who was white was working for that
opposition research fern the main source
behind the opposition research document
was a former spy who has now been
accused of lying to the FBI and his
sources for that document included
Clinton political operatives so these
are some of the examples of the problem
what it is that we're dealing with and
what counts as public corruption these
days I think the other thing that we
have to ask ourselves is what's the
environment that has allowed this to
happen how did we get to this point that
this has become routine and every day I
think there's two things in particular
and that when they're combined they
create this open field for this kind of
corruption one and it's one of these
things that we all know in our mind but
we don't necessarily realize the full
implication of and it's simply the size
of government now if you go and you talk
to the media and they put out their
stories they will point out that there
hasn't been an enormous shift in the
size of government over the last thirty
years they point out that back when
Reagan was president there was 1.7
million employees and today there are
only two million employees now I would
like to think that an additional 300,000
people in any environment is significant
I'm glad I'm not speaking tonight to
300,000 people by the way slightly
different than the size of this room but
the important thing here the difficulty
of keeping track of just an additional
300,000 people because that's your job
when you're trying to look after the
swamp and to give you an idea of what
these 300,000 people can get up to this
is one of my favorite stories of all
time from government over the past eight
years in 2012 the Department of Justice
announced a plea agreement with a guy
named John Beale anybody remember this
name see I think that's significant that
nobody even remembers this because it's
so common and happened so often this was
a 64 year old guy he had a 23 year
career at the Environmental Protection
Agency turns out that when he first
applied to the EPA in 1989 he claimed to
have a career as an assistant in the
Senate later turns out that that was
entirely fictitious and he'd never
worked for government before five years
later he came to the EPA as a dual
employee saying that in fact he was also
a CIA agent and this is why he needed to
not show up to work for months at time
because he was on secret missions for
the CIA okay
nobody ever checked up on that for 23
years okay well it was low 13 years
between 2000 and 2013 bill was absent
from work for a total of 2.5 years on
secret Langley missions okay he spent
$60,000 on undercover trips that turned
out to be visited visits to his
relatives in Los Angeles he spent
another 18 thousand dollars to get a
handicapped spa in Washington for the
illness he claimed he contracted while
he was serving in Vietnam of course he
had no illness and he'd never served in
Vietnam here's my favorite part in May
of 2011 Beale said he was retiring and
the entire department held a big goodbye
party for him and then nobody noticed
that he was still on the payroll for the
next 18 months while he did not show up
for work okay these are some of the
300,000 extra additional people you have
to keep track of in Washington by the
way he was one of the most highly paid
at the EPA because he'd worked there for
so long and done such good work not
showing up for two and a half years on
his spy missions that nobody noticed and
nobody noticed when he was gone
so there's a lot of people to keep track
of and a lot of ability for them to do
mischief the second part of this is that
we also live in an US government the
size and scope of which is now
unparalleled to anything we've seen in
the past I think it's fair to say that
we today live and what is increasingly
an administrative state there used to be
a time when those who are appointed at
the top those who were politically
accountable actually had a shot at
keeping track of everything that their
departments are trying to do and holding
some people to account but in a day when
the EPA is trying to regulate every
lawnmower for its carbon emissions and
regulate every puddle in the country and
when the IRS is responsible for
administering 80 thousand pages of
federal tax code and when the Health and
Human Services Department is running
health care for practically everyone in
the country the bureaucrats are going to
be in charge it's impossible for you to
have any oversight and moreover they're
in charge of programs and I think this
is important that precisely because they
are so big and so sweeping they are
designed to fail they cannot possibly
succeed you cannot have a Veterans
Affairs administration that with
government-run health care can be
expected to take care of the number of
veterans that they have promised to take
care of and do it well and so of course
there are going to be waiting lists and
of course because we live in a country
that does not accept such things you're
gonna have bureaucrats that are lying
and cheating and trying to cover it up
so in a way we've also allowed
government to grow to such a size that
we're almost guaranteeing these kind of
scandals come down the pike so you take
these two things to million federal
employees with sweeping discretion over
what
they can do and limitless programs that
are beyond the size of anything we've
ever done which are beyond
accountability by those in charge and
then you add to this what I mentioned at
the beginning this partisan approach
this when at every cost and you put that
attitude at the top of these federal
bureaucracies and you let it filter down
through the administration and of course
you're gonna get all the corruption just
listed because they take their cue from
the top if Hillary Clinton can set up
her own email server why can't every
federal employee talk off the grid and
by the way they do I have written more
about government scandals than I care to
admit and one of the central features of
every single one is a number of
government employees that were hiding
their communications from FOIA requests
and from transparency which by the way
ought to be your first sign that
something's going on because if you're
not willing to do what you do in the
open it's probably because you're doing
something wrong we still don't know by
the way to this day everything that Lois
Lerner did at the IRS and you want to
know why because we know from her email
records that she went out of her way to
conduct almost all of her internal
conversations on a special IRS instant
messaging system that she went and found
out and made sure was not tracked by the
federal government there's a great email
when she says is any of this recorded
someone said no and she said perfect
[Music]
again if the EPA is going to concoct an
entire carbon regulation program outside
the legislation why shouldn't every
bureaucrat go beyond what's allowed by
law that's how you get officials issuing
arbitrary regulations and fines that's
how you get a thousand Justice
Department officials that need remedial
ethics training and why you get entire
units of the IRS that didn't even blink
an eye when they received orders to
target thousands of Americans on the
basis of their political affiliation
just think about that dozens of career
IRS officials were involved in this
scheme and nobody blew the whistle for
four years they all thought it was an
okay thing to do
so that's your swamp people we've now
defined the problem and knowing all that
you might think I might have been
justified in coming up here and just
moving straight to drinks but here's the
good news the good news is that I'm not
alone and having realized some of these
problems out there far from it this is a
growing conversation in Washington
growing understanding that this is
something we have to focus on specific
in and of itself that it's not going to
fix itself that there needs to be
deliberate actions taken to change
what's going on there now president
Trump's way of summing this up in a kind
of Twitter like sentences we need to
drain the swamp which is a good
overarching theory but we actually have
a lot of people around him and in
Congress and an outside watchdog groups
and in grassroots organizations that
have been thinking far more deeply about
how you actually go about doing that and
we're starting to get some really good
proposals I think the quickest way you
can do it problem is that it isn't long
term the quickest way is you get leaders
into the White House and around the
president in the White House and in
these departments that are absolutely
determined to give the swamp less to
work with and to reset the rules of the
road because by the way the best way you
can cut down on this is to have fewer
regulations have fewer things that they
can cause mischief with and on this
specific question with just a few
exceptions I give the Trump
administration not just an a but in a
plus plus plus plus they have been
amazing
we are currently witnessing the greatest
era of deregulation ever hey and I don't
make that comparison to Reagan or anyone
else it's ever and part of that is
because Trump administration had a great
amount to work with when it came into
office given its predecessors but you
may remember in his first State of the
Union the president promised that he
would eliminate two regulations for any
new one that was created by the latest
statistics which I just got from the OMB
before I showed up here that ratio
currently stands at 22 eliminated to one
they have already got rid of 68 major
regulations which is no small feat and
they have a list of 450 that are on the
Block in the coming year now some of
this has been agency action but some of
it and I think Congress deserves its
fair share of applause here too via the
very aggressive use of something called
the Congressional review Act which
allows Congress with a simple majority
in both houses to overrule regulations
that were put into effect in the last
six months this Republican Congress to
its credit use that authority than
credible alacrity to get rid of some of
the worst final rulemaking of the Obama
era you've also had some incredible
folks that have come from the outside
that are all about reining in these
bureaucracies just last week I wrote a
piece about Mick Mulvaney at the Office
of Management and Budget who is a rock
star the rock star he is in a fight at
the moment and this may seem like a
little thing but it's actually enormous
he's in a fight right now with the
Treasury Department to require the IRS
for the first time in 40 years to submit
its rulemaking to White House review it
has never had to do that before
and think about how important that is
this is an IRS that doesn't like this
president isn't exactly huge fans of a
Republican Congress that's been beating
on it for the last six months and is
about to be in charge of implementing
the entire Republican tax reform I think
a little bit of oversight would be a
good thing this is the say mr. Mulvaney
another one of my favorite recent
stories who's currently acting
administrator the Consumer Financial
Protection Bureau they're not very happy
about that by the way you know but if
you haven't followed this fight the
woman that his predecessor installed in
that job as he was on the way out the
door is still pretending that she's the
Acting Administrator she's still sending
emails out to people just no one's
listening to her but she's camped out at
a building down the street it really is
a bizarre situation anyway the CFPB has
these extraordinary powers they're
called examination powers where they can
go choose any company out there and then
go in and look through any of its
records and continue fishing through
until they find a charge to bring which
isn't exactly how most of us think we go
about justice mr. Mulvaney is one of his
first acts informed the CFPB regulators
that before they could go ask a company
for all of its records they actually had
to develop a theory of wrongdoing this
is considered revolutionary in modern
Washington you've got Scott Pruett at
the EPA
he's redirecting his employees to go to
the top and most basic obligation of the
EPA to clean up Superfund sites the
Environmental Protection Agency might
actually start to voting its resources
to cleaning up the 1,300 Superfund sites
across the country significant numbers
of which have been on the list for 30
years but they all got put to the side
because it was much more important to
come up with a carbon agenda I recently
had a great conversation with interior
secretary Ryan Zinke he told me that
when he showed up he found out it had
been
come a routine at the Interior
Department under his predecessors to
demand enormous mitigation fees every
time a company applied for a basic
permit so you want a basic drilling
permit it's allowed under federal law
and regulation but you go to interior
and Terry says we're only going to give
you that permit if you give us like a
bajillion dollars to do this restoration
project over here and I remember Zinke
said to me if you have that
transactional demand in any other forum
outside of government the word we would
use for it is extortion and as I'm not
going to engage in government extortion
that practice is now at an end
so all this is encouraging but of course
the problem is its administration
specific you can reduce these roles you
can set these new guidelines but the
minute a new administration comes in
they can reverse it so of course the
most long-lasting thing we can do to
change all this is the hardest and
that's permanently reducing the size and
scope of government legislatively
Swallow smaller the swamp the fewer the
scandals I can remember very well a
congressman calling me up in the wake of
the IRS scandal and asking me running by
all these potential rules and
regulations he said do you think any of
this will help and I said you really
want to fix this come up with a flat tax
because when you have 80,000 IRS
employees and they have 74,000 pages of
a federal tax code that they have
discretion over you are going to have a
repeat of this at some point take away
their discretion to do it take away the
size of government and you take away a
lot of the swamp the recent tax form is
a good step in that direction
dramatically simplifies the codes
reduces the subsidies gets rid of the
deductions that are all the things that
allow the IRS to call up those audits
we've been now also passed a Veterans
Administration in the reform that's a
step toward introducing more market
forces into veteran's health care and
reducing federal management we've gotten
rid of the individual mandate and
Obamacare and other small parts of
Obamacare that give the state too much
control but these are still baby steps
we've got a long way to go these other
things that people are contemplating
legislatively that could also restore
some accountability one is legislation
that would require far more aggressive
transparency among federal officials and
real penalties for non-compliance we
currently and this is an astonishing
idea relay rely on the word of federal
employees that they are actually setting
forth and sending forth all of their
government communications or all of the
communications that they do on private
devices to their government accounts we
know that's not happening we know
everyone's hiding things we've got the
technology today to allow people to have
both a private account and
government account on their phone no one
should be allowed anymore to conduct a
business offline outside of the people's
views
there's also ideas to move certain
bureaucratic decision-making back under
the control of accountable officials why
on earth was the IRS ever in charge of
deciding what was politically acceptable
among nonprofit groups we have a body
called the Federal Election Commission
that was specifically set up to do that
it's got three Republicans three
Democrats it takes four votes to move on
it and we did that specifically to make
sure that there was no political
mischief we don't want the IRS or the
Securities and Exchange Commission the
Federal Communications Commission
telling companies nonprofits or
broadcasters what they're allowed to do
politically we need to make sure that
people who are accountable are taking
there again but to me the most exciting
part of the swamp training project
that's going on is something that has
gotten almost no attention but I think
in the long term is going to be the most
important if you go out right now
there's been a lot of attention the
White House has got for its judicial
pics and they deserve it because these
are very good pics but when you look all
of these pics have two things in common
it hasn't got much attention one is that
they rock star juris but the other is
that they are every single one of them
experts in administrative law because
there's been an entire generation of
judges that have come up and they have
understood the threat from
over-regulation from the abuse of
executive orders all the things that I
have mentioned so when you look at Neal
Gorsuch the Supreme Court
Steve grats on the 8th circuit done will
it on the per the piste circuit this is
the most notable aspect of them judge
Gorsuch one of the most remarkable
things about all of his jurisprudence
over all of his years was his outright
opposition to what's known as Chevron
deference and I know a lot of you out
there know what that means
the Chevron is a 1984 Supreme Court
decision and it holds that judges must
defer to agency interpretations of
federal law in any case where the law
seems ambiguous this is why we have the
event
straight up state that we have today
judge Gorsuch has ruled again and again
that this is an abdication of judicial
duty and he is right and I think what
you're going to begin seeing is in the
judiciary that is not going to take a
lot of the nonsense that's coming out of
the swamp anymore
[Applause]
so smaller government accountability
transparency check some balancing
balances there is something very
encouraging about knowing that the very
mechanisms our founders created to take
care of everything else could also drain
the swamp our task is to call out the
corruption as we see it label it
correctly and to think more creatively
about how we apply those fixes to make
sure we get rid of it in the end thank
you so much for your patience tonight
and I'm happy to have questions
we have some students with microphone
[Applause]
thank you case you're thinking that I'm
a really nice person by the way I went
out on my deck last night and took a
picture of the water tubes and sent it
and my kids and said haha you're not
here I think they're coming around with
microphones so I'm gonna wait
excuse me
Tim am I meant to call on people or are
they just gonna go web do i okay all
right
very thank you for that very informative
encouraging information you're speaking
of basically securing America and
there's one issue that you didn't touch
on criminal Sharia that is seditious
that's something that you must talk
about the people in this country do not
know about it we have a group that is
trying to inform the public and train
our law enforcement people about that
issue because as you know Mueller purged
all the information about the Muslim in
the Sharia Investigations that have been
going on thank you yeah there has been a
lot of talk about this especially in
wake of the shooting here in Florida
very tragic shooting here in Florida but
as we all know Christopher Rae came out
and admitted that the FBI failed to pass
on tips and this isn't just the first
time the FBI has failed to do that
there's been other situations not just
in terms of mentally ill shooters but
terrorist attacks where the FBI looks to
have dropped the ball they were alerted
to people the tsarnaev brothers for
instance up in Boston and did not act on
it and I think there are growing
questions about whether or not there is
a political correctness these days that
is influencing the bureau and somehow
undermining its ability to do its job so
that is something that definitely
matters
oh I have a very simple question what do
you expect from mr. Muller's
investigation in the next 6 to 12 months
that it will still be here I find it
very hard to believe
with all of the investigations that are
going on in Congress and with all of the
leaks that have come out of both his
investigation and those congressional
probes that if there was anything that
suggested any collusion between Donald
Trump and Russians we would know about
it it also just doesn't make a great
deal of sense
I always laugh people it's you can't
have it both ways especially those on
the left you either think the guys the
biggest loser in the world that can't
even manage to stumble through a
campaign but you can't think that and
then also think that he's a criminal
mastermind that pulled off a Russian
collusion thing and no one's found out
about it for 18 months like take your
pick okay but don't present him as both
within the same breath on CNN it's
ludicrous so you know will he go down
the road of obstruction I think that's
the interesting question the fact that
he came out on Friday with these
indictments of 13 Russians in these
groups I think a lot of people are
hoping that this was the kind of
crescendo of his investigation and that
he's gonna wrap things up it would be
good for the country if he did so and if
we could move on I know there were some
Democrats out there and said well you
know this indictment did not absolve the
Trump administration well go back and
read any of the two bajillion
indictments that the Justice Department
they never absolved someone indictments
are about I didn't have need to convict
someone the fact that they put the word
unwitting in there the fact that rod
Rosenstein went out of his way in his
press conference to say that it's
important to know what wasn't in this
allegation that there was no American
that has been accused of knowing
anything about Russian collusion
suggests that there isn't much there
there so
we can hope that in the coming months he
closes it up because we just don't have
I think any evidence that the basis of
this probe was I mean look in fairness
he was given order to look into Russian
interference in the election he's now
come out with indictments laying out the
scheme and how that happened I think
we're a long way from collusion or
obstruction charges and it would be best
for the country if we could move on a
question in a comment yes sir question
is I really admire tom Fitton
what he's doing what Judicial Watch and
maybe you would comment on that and then
the comment would be you represent the
new George Washington of America thank
you well I have hair dye tom Fitton does
amazing work in Washington and I think
the reason everyone yeah he's
extraordinary
judicial watch is extraordinary and I'll
tell you why because he can do things
this is amazing he told this to me
himself and a lot of people don't
appreciate this congressional
investigators can because as you can see
from the subpoenas that came out that I
was describing you can send a subpoena
to an agency of government and they can
ignore you and until you go and and
threaten them with contempt nothing can
be done and then you know even then you
can hold them in contempt and then what
do you do if the Justice Department
isn't even going to enforce your
contempt citation which it has a habit
of not doing or you can believe it or
not and I'm an advocate of this it turns
out did you know Congress has its own
police force and they can jail you we
haven't ever done it in the history of
the public but I'm all for trying it at
least once
and so but the great thing about
Judicial Watch is it gets to use Freedom
of Information Act laws and you put a
request in to an agency and if they do
not respond to you within a certain
amount of time you file a lawsuit and
then in court is involved and they can
compel the agencies to provide you
information so we're in this completely
bizarre situation where tom Fitton is
more capable of getting information
about what the government did then our
congressional overseers and that should
tell you something about how wrong
everything is in d.c these days but he
is dogged at any one time they have
something like 300 lawsuits on the go
and they have individually pulled out
more information about the Clinton
Foundation Clinton email servers what's
been happening with the Trump event
ocation the IRS scandal and every other
scandal combined than any other
organization in Washington and that guy
deserves the Presidential Medal of
Freedom
this will be our last question
good evening one of the first things
President Reagan did during his first
term in no offense was to appoint jp2
Grace who organized the Grace Commission
in the last book he wrote before he died
he said had Congress implemented all
2,000 plus regulations in our
recommendations we could have saved four
hundred and fifty billion dollars over a
five year period my question is isn't
that the fastest way to drain the swamp
so I think Commission's are good ideas
if their recommendations are followed
and that's one of the problems look the
quickest way to drain the swamp would be
for this Congress to pass president
Trump's budget which calls for 30 to 40
percent reductions in some of the worst
agencies in Washington but they lack the
political will to do that and they lack
the political will to tackle
entitlements to tackle welfare reform
and to tackle some of the biggest
programs out there that is what gives a
swamp their ability to continue growing
and causing so many problems so I think
there's even faster ways than to do it
was a commission my worry about Blue
Ribbon panels I think that it's always
great to have outside eyes do something
like that but the sad reality is is that
often their recommendations are not
taken on board and do not happen and so
much of what we need to have done if we
want to fix this from a long-term
perspective is legislative and that's
gonna require a class of House and
senators that is a lot more willing to
take chances than we have had and seen
in recent years but I think it's a good
idea I just would like to see it
actually get done thank you all
[Applause]